Tina Knowles Lawson is one proud grandma  [Music]  it's clear blue ivy is taking after her  famous parents and Beyonce's mom is  cheering her on after she made her big  debut  mama Tina and Solange son Jules were  jamming out in the car to five-year-old  blues freestyle a surprise bonus track  on her dad jay-z's four four four albums  Tina captioned the cute Instagram video  quote Blue Ivy Carter spitting out them  rhymes I think it's genius I mean like  all of his projects I thought it was  really great over the weekend et spoke  to the formation singers mom about how  the Carter family is adjusting to their  newest additions roomie and sir how do I  be doing as a big sister she enjoying  her younger sibling Airy proud and very  excited she's a great big yes she really  cares for them a lot yeah  [Music]